después de cinco días de protestas en
cali ya que el combustible en muchas de
las estaciones de aledañas y está la
única estación por acá cerquita que
tiene combustible los caleños están
haciendo horas de fila para poder
repostar sus vehículos es primera vez
que se vive aquí la verdad es primera
vez que te lo veo yo creo que te violo
el paro ya no hay ningún otro motivo
sin embargo el apoyo a las protestas de
la ciudadanía es muy amplio
todo grande esfuerzo tiene des por una
gran causa entonces hay que apoyar
también al paro estas imágenes no sólo
se han reducido a las estaciones de
gasolina también en supermercados y en
bancos
dos horas siendo fila y todavía me falta
otra otra ahora tengo el turno 20 tengo
mi esposa haciendo fila ya estamos como
venezuela nos burlamos de venezuela y
está muy igual pero también en servicios
públicos romano en el sector donde estoy
hoy acá mi casa no hay energía no hay
agua
las protestas en cali han ido
acompañadas de bloqueos en los accesos a
la ciudad
la central de abastecimientos del valle
reportó que un domingo normal llegan
3.500 toneladas de alimentos a la ciudad
este domingo no ha llegado ningún camión
una situación que los caleños temen que
se pueda alargar con nuevos paros y con
la llegada de la mina indígena
movilizaciones a pesar de la retirada de
la reforma tributaria